i'm very pleased to be able to say that
joe biden is not yet the president-elect
because the thought of having guys
like zeke emanuel in charge of diseases
not a good thing
the idea of having guys like ben rhodes
in charge of foreign policy
not a good thing fortunately though this
has not been decided yet and some crazy
news out of politics
aoc says she might leave politics the
future of the democratic party
according to the dnc chairman tom perez
might leave politics she just gave an
interview
to the new york times she said i
genuinely don't know
i don't even know if i want to be in
politics you know for real in the first
six months of my term
i didn't even know if i was going to run
for re-election this year it's the
incoming it's the stress it's the
violence it's the lack of support from
your own party
it's your own party thinking you're the
enemy but i'm serious when i tell people
the odds of me running for higher office
and the odds of me
just going off trying to start a
homestead somewhere they're probably the
same says aoc
now at the same time aoc is angling
herself to try to enter the cabinet if
joe biden
is named the president so
people in politics do this all the time
they say sir senator senator are you
considering running for president
well now i just love the job i'm doing i
don't know if i want to run for
president you know
sir sir are you thinking of ready for
congress now listen i love being a small
business owner
but if my country called me to serve
maybe i would right so there's this long
tradition in politics of pretending that
you're not interested in politics
even though obviously you are that's why
you were in the political arena so i
don't i don't really take aoc's comments
at face value
but i do believe that she has had enough
of congress
i don't think aoc particularly enjoys
being in congress that much
i think she is being stymied in things
that she wants to do i think congress is
a total grind
i think you got to spend most of your
money right most of your time rather
raising money
i think you got to travel back and forth
to that district a lot i think as
lbj said the difference between the
senate
and congress is the difference between
chicken salad
and chicken excrement and i think that's
all probably true and aoc knows it and
frankly i don't even know that she wants
to be in the senate because the senate
can't get very much done either
but something tells me she wouldn't mind
being in that cabinet if joe biden is
elected president
something tells me she's angling for
that and that's very
dangerous because right now aoc still
has i guess some sort of democratic
accountability to the people
but with the growth of the liberal
progressive administrative state
more and more you have these czars
implemented you have people
who come in and run departments who have
basically no accountability to the
people at all
and who are able to effectively write
the laws that govern us
without any kind of vote without even
the public knowing very much about it
that's what you're going to see if joe
biden is elected president there will be
a
massive growth in the administrative
apparatus
and who could be in charge of it my
goodness gracious you could even get
people like
aoc in there the stakes are very high
that's why it's very important
not to concede a single thing until the
legal process
plays out until the legal ballots are
are counted un until the legal illegal
ballots are thrown out
or until the court stops the whole
process because
time has run out there is no reason
though to make a hasty concession right
now
there is a lot on the line i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts